fake blood capsules oh they didn't have
any
really
that's gross i love it we are throwing a
halloween party at our house it's gonna
be the greatest thing ever someone will
die of fun and of murder there's gonna
be beer pumpkins bloody goblins fake
ones it's gonna be awesome we have
decorations dead people that we just
murdered not murdered but pictures of
dead people from tv or movies mutilated
bodies but fake ones candy dancing
tequila all kinds of food and snacks
blood orphans no blood orphans
i
i don't know what that is so you're a
princess too hey oh for the last four
years everything has been princesses
every book every movie every backpack
all princesses all the time oh that
sounds fun it's a nightmare
excuse me i just have to file a quick
report i'm applying to the police
academy soon and the
manual says i have to work on my
observation skills so
tree leaves
night
sky
hand andy's hand
what else you got
oh no vice principal emergency what is
it i have to leave
some idiot kids were caught pooping on
the soccer field
oh too bad guess trick-or-treating's
over
no we can walk him around it's no
problem we just got started oh that's so
sweet of you
now ladies princess mommy has to go and
take care of some bad guys so you be
nice to ron and andy okay
okay
let's go to the next house i need to go
to the bathroom
i i have no idea what to do about that
halloween is my favorite holiday it's
just the best and i don't have to work
hey [ __ ] teenage girls dressed as sexy
kittens pump your own stomachs this year
oh one more thing the people in this
room now are the people i invited plus
leslie and donna so don't tell anybody
who's not invited then hey
what's going on cupcake excited about
the party tonight
oh
oh you're coming um i was just about to
tell you jerry already told me
can't wait to see how tiny your costume
is
what time's the start
seven
perfect yeah it's perfect
hello anne
hey
i early nope you are right on time
i like your costume oh thanks raggedy
ann it's one of my favorite books when i
was a kid
i'm a pirate right
oh hey dr harris how how are you
thanks
um this is ron swanson from the parks
department i know him from that thing
that i'm doing this is dr harris
you're a doctor yeah
i meant your costume i got it
world's colliding
always awkward
donna
blue shirt
badge
night stick
you
are a policewoman
yep you're a regular sherlock holmes i
solved that mystery before you did
okay this is fun
andy you are ufc legend chuck liddell
that's right
girl from the ring
to me sherlock holmes is literally the
greatest character in the western canon
smart intuitive handsome
replaces pasty british frailty with
superhuman physical fitness and you get
sherlock traeger
it's the death canoe
get your foot out the water dumbass it's
blood lake now i missed the first three
death canoe films why exactly is it a
death canoe does it tip over easily read
my twitter feed i live tweeted the first
three this morning in preparation in the
fifth one the canoe is actually the hero
it's a crazy twist oh caterpillar
thank you
hey guys come on in
welcome to the den of horrors where's
all the scary stuff scary stuff is
invisible leah broken dreams
disappointment achieving your greatest
goal having it all fall apart and
knowing that you'll never climb any
higher
can we have some candy i'm gonna give
you something sweeter than candy ryan
the truth it's very possible that some
of you have already peaked it's all
downhill from here turkeys okay let's
say goodbye to ms knope kids it is ms
knope it's not a city councilwoman note
because that chapter in my life is
already over just remember kids
nothing gold can stay
i need to get more chips
great
come on walk no this is a pacifist
protest had enough you need to let go of
me come on yeah get it that's good oh
here we go
he's got us back
nice
yeah oh my god andy i am so sorry
oh
psych
blood capsules
what yeah
i wanted to shock you into expressing
your anger
and that way
my nose is broken oh my god i gotta go
to the hospital
did it feel good yeah
yep
hey guys
hey
remember my boyfriend derek and his
boyfriend ben yeah hi
it's totally okay that you didn't wear a
costume
i did i'm a straight person
hey sorry i'm late see
sorry it's a little bit lame right now
but
we'll get it going i passed up a gay
halloween party to be here do you know
how much fun gay halloween parties are
last year i saw three jonas brothers
make out with three robert pattisons
it was amazing
hello sir we're sober we would like to
get tattoos in our bodies because we
love each other tattoos this is a pawn
shop
but yeah sure i can do that
[Applause]
look what he's doing he's breaking pens
this is the idea
of the century right here wow
come here
babe you look more beautiful right now
than i have ever seen you
wow
just your luck that you're going into
labor on halloween can i get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no i want
it on that's the whole point i put the
makeup on after i went into labor
whatever blows your skirt up okay you
ready to push
wait no babe my birth mix
[Music]
he did the monster bash
bert macklin jr
um we need a halloween angle how about
demon spawn baby satan dwyer oh i like
that yeah or
uh maybe bert snakehole
ludgate
karate dracula macklin demon
jack-o'-lantern dwight we call him jack
for short
you